all right
gotcha
[Music]
demo of that
this is a kognito thing right
has to do without them
and ninja realness the shinobi
Oh ninja
[Music]
right now
let me do it
Hawkins
ninja school if you ever played ninja
school for example graphics let me tell
you
we're lucky
Oh
Oh
have you done your reading
the world shake
Oh
ee la king
[Laughter]
[Music]
also becoming to the switch I believe
first we thought might outcome as well
we're here let's go
Fuji's
[Laughter]
we put the sword to the chest whatever
scroll scrolls I noticed so Laura
Kathleen essence of ninja games
[Laughter]
nice visible earth
I guess that was the prologue of a scene
you know
I look down to collect objects
the target
[Music]
they gave them the soft touch
then example
yeah the background is parallax
scrolling if anybody understand that is
our technique they have the background
of
see simulate dynamic
they look at monkey for inviting people
oh absolutely shadolo month man yeah
really only got the low okay that's a
store long Cognito unbounded store he
could purchase various ninja heart which
as you know in the world
Lyndsey's house had silenced shots
purchase some magical items
to deal with all the various entities
climbing claws o bowels of the White
Lotus
the skill tree skill trade though so its
depth to it yeah you know something is
something that our perches on my switch
because like last name the team's gonna
use some Damon so I got my switch with
me yeah I got a switch down there look
like
the middle right there and push it up
stay tuned after this match
develop it
of this beautiful game oh he got smashed
in bad
Wow
[Music]
Oh Ellen so neither look like you do in
the Sun no fun
alright thank you Rock want me like that
revealing all of them
I don't know why defeating him make sure
that's a question too
evolution
this
is enough your currency
whatever long ago
you know you know Louise
or the department
back to this demeans
due to me Jawa express our man channel
with the ice learning day that I was
told you only have a few minutes to try
the game
press and hold to jump my upon to deploy
the wind suit
oh he just purchased a boutique or dog
pack Nino has battled with a pinky claw
[Music]
when I got back oh yeah and I had it oh
that's my connector eat you all right I
think that's why I call it a movie
Oh
check it out check it out check out
Oh
[Music]
Oh
he's not gonna get it up down so just
let them never see him
[Music]
love absolutely so tell me more about
the message to tell means more like as
far as obviously must consume their own
book like the litigated classic 8-bit
yeah you know tell people about it
definitely seems okay yeah so and you're
such a good thing because the players
expectation are the core gave this idea
that we're using with this game so it's
presented as so your premium so yeah so
you just play this board ninja right in
the world is stuck in a curse and you
don't get to leave your affiliates or do
the trading day at night and apparently
some demons will come back in there like
ah that's so boring I wish I could go in
an adventure you doing it so you're
basically you're born and you have to go
to the class to hear about prophecies
about a scroll and if you wrote I'm
actually in at the time of greatest need
and you're like man whatever so have you
seen demons come back of the day you
pick up the controller right and that's
what you start and so you get attacked
and then some hero flies in and the nick
of time arrives are the Phoenix amazing
you're going to see yeah yeah hey no
time to explain right you got to grab
that scroll and carry it so you get to
leave the village now ahead across the
world that's stuck in the
beside my carrots and you have to make
it to the top of the Norway mountain
right with the stroke
so you're the messenger right this
oxygen you're carrying your hair in the
scroll scroll parallel to the survival
of your plan destiny and so you just
start up under its present as a linear
8-bit actual platformer waterville after
the other right technically not an RPG
but still a bit of a character
progression lay yes you know like so to
be on the show and you get a few
upgrades so I see there's probably other
climbing club - climbing well and so
eventually you also get a witness suit
you also get a grappling hook and so the
game is like that for the first few
hours forget about ten levels and then
something happens and it basically
exploded to 60 because you were said
that's where but when the messenger was
needed right so now you're 500 years
into the future okay so we got a little
bit of time-travel going on okay guys
and so that is supportive visually by
you know shifting to one console
generation of the head if you are so
we're going from 8-bit to 16 exactly as
though now is the 16-bit when he had a
different suit on
yeah all right there in fact trust that
if you go through that stream here you
know you have like four to two 8-bit
it's more simple and it's dollars you
know and no animation that your Garrick
it's kind of like but then here it gets
super smooth like more frames and
renovation driver and this is way you
get the year soon and yeah so at this
point you also I just killed myself here
hey tell me about this guy this guy so
this is horrible
demo version but it's not
okay so base Pete the deal with Marvel
is that Marvel controls time so whenever
you are about to die
it was stuck will appear to stuff
everything
it's kind of like Union you get out of
jail free card yeah so Betsy the latest
checkpoint as you see how he took a
little notepad at room that's your depth
to him are saving your life
and so he speaks her own better like
that thoughts kept reminding
but he also steals your liver yeah until
the death is repaid or the way he's 40
just raise your feet
so this point you have the wingsuit so
you gather against the guide and also
infect our and also a row
like slingshot I got you
see we're both just all week he also
gives me like a big bag of textual one
line
seems like there's
I'll see where you
I love
and against that switching it just on
the fly
take the 16 there yeah so you know
that's right because you know you know
there's an opening somewhere
you gotta be good trick to find up pored
over them back dragon super
so they really are is being indicated
mentioned I guess is that so again is
first presented as a national opera
after you record a 16-bit
open up your bath you know you'll be
looking for like you artifacts and yes
for your power-ups and let you access
new areas new levels but they're all bus
now as far as the the boss now you said
out that I'm comedy levels we have we're
talking it saw the deported first quest
we don't want to give away to budget
whatever
for the first lesson 10 levels and now
our horse gets through that's now each
level would talk in boss fights at the
end of each level yes a 14 question
right so well I'll show you so here in
the in the categories at the end we
fight against the necromancer because
we're you know sort of the light or
flashing portions rights or compulsory
Eric
those all the 8-bit soundtrack in there
any tracker
sometimes he doesn't NES exported oh my
god you've gone for that classic feel
audio sound absolutely so you know we're
just craving experiences that virtual
information yeah absolutely what it was
about at the end of the day this is what
it was about
absolutely so that's the thing they
would ever think that that would say off
you know these all games but the main
thing
right examine we want to make the team
as good as our memory of these inside
that the exactly the way these hands
work because outside of a
you know controls are usually stiff
that's why I'm such a metadata back you
know so we're trying to strike it to the
next level they were also looking at
I kind of like the little something then
you don't want to be like a the game's
over they start again from the beginning
go back to the shop absolutely
okay now as don't think you have that
skill tree yeah and I can upgrade in
Lhasa so much an order
so the chapters for if you're curious
yeah so
you can always talk about whatever
Harriet goes into Chuck Bieber yeah
Chuck you go up something to say about
where you know
so for example here
it's like you've you've been to kind of
get was before a games right
so it's pretty much again like a level
overview yeah and then that's also you
can ask about the boss
you can also start asking about red
you know it's like it doesn't make sense
if you starting to doubt the shopkeeper
like about 80% of birds
oh now we're talking crazy
walks right now
[Music]
so again wedding is nothing at a store
as a release release window check it out
this summer
okay
so we're gonna have that increment sirs
big big moment here
necromancy right hand
classic ninja gayden style horses
what's up on let's naptime yeah see ya
yeah
animals nation got overthrown
did you wash our hair oh yeah was that
masseur a few it was
um it's kind of like every with you it's
like a magical sure yeah and then it was
that was an ability
all right nice it's so for busters you
know here we have our end screen here we
have a teaser of a bigger one and the
lower right there
arkaid go live at some point in the name
Parcells fantastic everything's
over-the-top but at the same time paying
homage to the classic this is fantastic
so we're coming out on switch switch at
their PC as well PC and Xbox so we will
be looking at the the demand we're using
an Xbox controller to play on PC because
it's just in my opinion into the past so
what's up yeah that's good but yeah I
mean we definitely want to bring the
game to anyone will play it you know but
we're a very small team and so you know
the switch is really where it lives for
us you know being inspired by the NES
and all of that their relationship with
Nintendo is just the natural fit you
know cuz repeats it on TV so yeah yeah
and I mean they're just great for the
news and everything so right now we've
come which works so yeah should be a
switch and PC at lunch and we have
nothing else to announce yet and it gave
me talking a little better power let's
received a release window these windows
it will be the summer
probably like late summer if you wanna
manage expectations you don't have a
date yet so it's being published by
devolver too which is amazing so working
with devolver you know it's it's also a
dream come true for us so yeah so I mean
we're we're still you know
so so we should we should announce a
date the coming up and I'm looking
forward to this is our games I was most
anticipated here at PAX
Caramanica I'll sit down but thank you
very much tag me to the ninja guy